مع بدايه عرضه في شهر رمضان المبارك حقق
برنامج كفو نجاحا كبيرا واصبح حديثا الناس
على مواقع التواصل البرنامج يعرض على ام
بي سي ومنصه شاهد بشكل مجاني ويسلط الضوء
على الشخصيات الملهمه في المجتمع السعودي
البرنامج يقدم تجارب اشخاص قدموا تضحيات
ومواقف بطوليه متحدين متحدين الصعاب
والظروف المحيطه ليكون نموذجا مشرفا للعمل
الانساني اليوم سيكون ضيفنا احمد الشيخ
مخرج برنامج كفو لحديث اكثر عن تجربه
الناجحه والفكره التي لاقت قبول الناس
[موسيقى]
حسيت انه انا موفي
كده احلى مفاجاه صارت في حياتي كلها انا
لحد الان متفاجئ ومصدوم عن اللي جالسه
اشوفه قدام الحين ايش هذا اللي انتوا
عملتوا
اثرت كثير بصراحه يعني انا ما قدرت امسك
نفسي حاولت اني ما ابكي لكن
شكرا
انت كفو انت كفو انت كفو كفو كفو كفو انت
كفو كفو
من المنامه ينضم لنا مخرج برنامج كفو
واحمد الشيخ احمد اهلا بك معنا رمضان كريم
كل عام وانت بخير يا مرحبا فيكم وكل عام
وانتم بالف خير طيب بدايه
لماذا انتج برنامج
كفو ما هدفه
برنامج كفو هو تكريم الشخصيات الكفر اللي
لهم اعمال انسانيه ولهم يعني مواقف
وتضحيات ومش ظاهرين اعلاميا يعني ما
ينظرون للشهره احنا نخليهم مشهورين هاي
الفكره الاساسيه
طيب استاذ احمد في هذه الحاله كيف بتم
عمليه اختيار ابطال البرنامج بشكل عام نعم
طبعا عندنا فريق بحث فريق كبير يبحث في
مثلا المملكه العربيه السعوديه من اكثر من
منطقه من جيزان من تبوك من الرياض فالفريق
يرشح مجموعه شخصيات طبعا عن طريق معارسهم
عن طريق بعض الاشخاص اللي سمعوا القصص عن
طريق الصحافه اللي انكتبهوا بعض قصصهم
فاحنا نقوم نلخص هذه الاشخاص كلهم
عرضهم واختيار الاشخاص اللي متاكد منها
طبعا المره الاختيار في اكثر من مرحله
منها نتاكد من صحه المعلومات تاكد من قصه
ليه ما يتم اختيارهم مفاجئتهم طبعا من غير
ما يدرون نهائيا طيب احمد خلال برنامج كفو
ما هو اصعب موقف بطولي تم تصوي
والله المواقف كثير صعبه طبعا اصعب مرحله
احنا ان الشخص ما يدري ان احنا راح نصور
كفو ما يدري انه هو في مرحله التصوير
اساسا الاشخاص كلهم يعني مصورهم من غير ما
يدرون فهذه اصعب مرحله لكن اصعب تصوير كان
بالنسبه لنا هو تصوير في محطه القطار كان
تصويرنا لكن عندنا فقط ثلاث ساعات لازم
نصور ونجهز حق التصوير في ثلاث ساعات نجهز
السيت اب ونفس الوقت نصور فعشان هذا الشيء
قمنا فريق العمل
قامت وسوى هيرسل بروفات تبرع محطه القطار
انه كيف نسوي ستر في عشر دقايق فكان اكبر
تحدي عندنا يمكن
ندرب الفريق انه يسوي بشكل سريع بعشر
دقائق راح نجهز
كان اصعب موقف وموقف غريب طبعا بالنسبه
لنا شلون نصور كامل في ثلاث ساعات طيب
يعني هذا البرنامج تصدر ترند في مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي ووصف واحدث صدمه لفريق
العمل خصوصا في السعوديه ما الذي حصل
اولا ان توقعنا بنروح المملكه العربيه
السعوديه راح نلقى يعني
وانصدمنا ان القصص كثير عندنا يعني حصلنا
تقريبا 600 قصه
موجوده فكان صعوبه ان نختار 30 من 600 قصه
قصص ما شاء الله في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه والناس الكفر كثار شخص او شخصين
ما شاء الله بالمئات والالوف بعد فهذه
كانت اكبر ص في صدمه ثانيه انه نختار
الشخص نبي نصور معاه اهله موجودين في
مناطق مختلفه في المملكه وتبعد كل منطقه
كمان ساعات عشر ساعات بالسياره سواء او
بالطياره مسافات كبيره فهذه بعد شويه كان
صعب على على يعني عشان تكتمل حلقه واحده
نضطر نزور اربع خمس مناطق ونصور في ايام
عديده عشان نعرض لكم عشر دقائق مده الحلقه
هذه كان صدمه بالنسبه لنا البرنامج حقق
تفاعل ونجاح كبير انت كمخرج للبرنامج اين
يكمل سرنجه
السر انا اتوقع في عاملين رئيسيين اولا
العفويه البرنامج غير مصطنع اللي تشوفونه
كله مشاعر حقيقيه
الفريق العملي يتاثر فريق العمل يبكي وهو
يقدم لكم هاي
الحلقات
الشغله الثانيه والسر الثانيه تكاتف فريق
العمل فريق العمل كله متكاتب عشان يوصل
رساله وهدف اللي هو ان هذه الشخص كفء لانه
عمل تضحيه هذه فهذه السبب العفويه وحرص
فريق العمل ككل وليس فقط كمخرج عن فريق
متكامل حرصنا كلنا ان احنا نوصل هذه
الرساله انا اتوقع هذا هو السر ورا نجاح
هذا هو سر نجاح البرنامج استاذ احمد ولكن
هل تعتقدون بان الجمهور العربي الشارع
والبلدان العربيه بحاجه هكذا نوع من
البرامج
[موسيقى]
يعني عدوى عمل الخير شكرا جزيلا لك من
المنامه مخرج برنامج كفو احمد الشيخ شكرا
لك لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات